BELLEMARE WITH THE AVS A COUPLE
OF SEASON
IS ROBBED.
HIT LANDESKOG IN THE BACK SIDE.
DOWNTOWN.
[ HORN ]
>> THE AVS HAVE TAKEN A 1-0E A
BIG-TIME SERIOUS CONTENDERED FOR
THE STANLEY
IN FRONT -- SCORE!
[ HORN ]
>> DEVON TOEWS A HAVE -- IS HAVR
SHOT SAVED BY KUEMPER. A SURE
UP TOP FOR CALE MAKAR.
THIS IS WHY THEY WIN
STANLEY CUPS. PLAYED
WITH EACH OTHER FOR SO LONG.
DOWN THE IT A LOT OVER THE COURE
OF THE FIRST 44 GAMES. MOMENT O.
TURNOVER.
HERE'S CIRELLI, SENDS IT FAR
HAPPEN.
HE WASN'T GONNA BE ABLE TOAL, HE
SHOOTS AN SCORNS! TRAIN.
AND JOE, FROM WHERE HED OUT OF S
UNDER THE GOAL LINE. BOUNCED OFS
SKATE.
NEWHOOK MAKES AN UNREAL --
COULDN'T DO IT.
IT'S FED OFF FOR J.T.
ACROSS TO MAKAR.
WHAT A PLAY! THE LIGHTNING
AND BRAYDEN POINT,
TO --  ON
SERGACHEV.
LANDESKOG TO THE POINT.
TOEWS, SAYS I WILL FIND JACK
N GOAL.
THE AVALANCHE ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THINGS TIME-OUT.
FIND THE GLASS AND IT IS KEPT IN
BY A SLIDING SERGACHEV.
THREE.
OH, MAN!
>> I THOUGHT JANUARY WAS GOINGG.
KUCHEROV LOOKS AGAIN, A THE WORR
SAVE AT THE END OF THE GAME, THE